Let us make this example a little bit more complicated, complicated enough that
it cannot be proven simply by applying one instance of modus ponens.
Imagine that when the robot found that,
imagine that the robot proved to itself that this box is not liftable.
And the humans in the factory,
who are trying to make fun of the robot said to the robot,.
Well the reason it's not lift-able is not because it's not movable, but
because the batteries aren't working.
So, now this situation is more complicated, the robot must also check it's back.
So, now the robot begins a slightly different knowledge base, so
suppose that the knowledge in this knowledge base is.
Cannot move, and battery full means it's not lift-able.
It finds from its percepts again it cannot move.
So it checks its battery, and it checks its battery, and
finds that the battery is full.
So there are two new sentences that get written in the knowledge base.
Now, the knowledge base contains three sentences.
As earlier, in resolutions you're improving, the agent must convert all these
sentences in its knowledge base into a conjunctive novel form.
That means that these sentences can, can contain a literal or
a disjunctional literals, or a conjunction of disjunctional literals.
So, if we begin by removing the implication from sentence one,
because an implication cannot occur in a conjunctive normal form.
So when we remove implication from the first sentence, we get this sentence.
When a sentence is not yet satisfactory it is not a conjunct to normal form.
Because this is a dis-junction of conjunctions, and
what we want are conjunctions or dis-junctions.
So we apply the deMorgan's law, and now we get the following sentence.
We're simply taking the negation inside, which flips the conjunction into
a disjunction, and now we have three literals connected with this junction, and
this is a conjunctive novel form, this junction of literals.
So, now we have in the knowledge base three sentences.
All three of them in the conjunctive normal form, either literals or
disjunctional literals.
Recall that the robot wanted to prove not lift-able.
So it takes the negation of that, this is,
again, proof by refutation, so it considers lift-able.
So now this knowledge base has four sentences, these four sentences coming from.
The negation of what it wants to prove.
Once again, the reasoning begins by the literal that it wants to prove,
in this case, liftable.
And it finds a sentence in which the negation of literal is true.
So once again,
we begin with the sentence S4, because that is what we want to prove.
And we find a sentence in the knowledge base, which contains a lift-able which
is a negation of lift-able in the sentence s four that we want to prove.
We resolve on this because they both cannot be true and
resolution here is to be subtract that we drop them.
Now in the sentence S one that is under consideration currently we have
two lift-ables.
We can begin with either one of them.
Let us begin with not battery full.
We'll try to find a sentence,
which contains a negation of this particular clause.
It is a sentence, S3, which is the negation of this, so we resolve on this,
battery full and not battery full because they both cannot be true.
We'll drop them.
Now in sentence, S1, we're left with just one literal, can move.
We can try to find a sentence in knowledge base which can Here it is.
And so we can resolve on them, and we dissolve on them.
We drop them.
And once we drop them then we have a null condition, which stands for
a contradiction.
So you reached a contradiction.
Therefore the assumption that this was lift-able cannot be
true therefore not lift-able is true, and
we have just shown that resolution in this case proves what wanted.
One important point to note here is that a focused of
because of the conjunctive novel form.
One important point to notice here is the focus of attention.
Often, when the problem space is very complex.
For example, when the number of sentences is very large,
the sentences are very complex,
it can become really hard to the logical agent to decide what to focus on.
But, because we have converted at a conjunctive normal form, and
because resolutions [INAUDIBLE] is making use of resolution.
Therefore, at any particular time,
the logical agent knows exactly what to focus on.
You always began with this literal.
You always try to find a sentence which contains this negation.
You always resolve on that.
You take out the remaining literal in this sentence and proceed forward.
This focus of attention,
this computational efficiency of resolution theorem proving, is arising because.
Or what are called Horn Clauses.
A Horn Clauses is a disjunction, it contains at most one positive literal.
This is happening is S1,
this is a disjunction that contains at most one positive literal.
This is a negative literal, this is a negative literal.
And the fact that it contains just one positive literal is a very powerful idea,
because that's where the focus of attention comes from.